The Du hast du Angst. Musik Musik Musik
Musik
Musik Jo, hallo und herzlich willkommen zur neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO. Herzlich willkommen natürlich auch wieder im Studio. Wie immer ihr kennt ihn, ihr liebt ihn, er ist hier Stefan T. Und wie immer gegenüber von mir eine Gestalt, das ihr unter dem Namen Flo und den Willkern. Herzlich willkommen, das war, muss man sagen, halb Regen, halb Gewitter, halb Horror-Intro. Vielen Dank an Sophie für dieses fantastische Intro. Klang aber auch ein bisschen wie der Eurovision Song und der Beitrag von Moldawien 2008. So ein Klagesang, moldawischer Klagegesang. Ja. Kennst du noch R.L. Stine, der diese Gänsehautbücher gemacht hat? Nee, die kannte ich mal. Der hat mich ans Schreiben gebracht. R.L. Stine, der macht jetzt eine Masterclass. Und ich frag mich, was das für eine Masterclass ist. Bei Masterclass, bei einem Programm, wo berühmte Leute ihre Geheimnisse preisgeben. Er hat so eine Taschenlampe unter dem Kinn und das ist so dumm. Ja, und er erzählt ... Ja, vor allem ... Lektion Nummer eins. Ja, ich find das ganz spannend, weil er hat einfach immer gruselige Geschichten erzählt, die immer nach dem gleichen Muster funktioniert haben meistens. Kinder gehen irgendwo hin und da ist dann was gruselig und dann gehen sie wieder. Aber kennst du die Musik von Gänsehaut? Da gab es dann auch mal eine Serie oder so, dieses Dam dam dam dam dam Geschichten aus der Gruppe Wann ist wieder Halloween, Mann, ich vermiss Halloween immer. Das ist immer so nach dem Halloween ist vor Halloween für mich irgendwie. Immer wenn es vorbei ist und ich dann ganz traurig so die Spinnenweben-Deko abhänge. Ich bin dieses Jahr am Anfang November in Mexico. In Mexico. Und da ist, weil die glaube ich am 2. November feiern die Ah, Cinco de Mayo. Nein, feiern die Via de los Muertos. Den Tag der Toten, dem auch in Spectre, im neuesten James-Bond-Installment, ist es ja auch. Da sind die am Anfang, laufen die, das ist nächstes Jahr. Da versteckt er sich unter der Maske, ne? Und dann laufen die ja durch Mexico City, wo dann diese große Parade der Dia de los Muertos ist. Und dann ist es ja eine sehr, sehr coole Szene, so eine Planenz. Und ich frage mich wahnsinnig darauf, dass ich genau zu dem Tag in Mexiko bin, wo ich natürlich auch so eine Skelettenmaske male. Was für ein riesiger Zufall, dass James Bond sich dazu entscheidet, genau den syrischen Spion genau an dem Tag hochzunehmen, wo diese Parade ist, wo sie denkt so, okay, wir müssen den jetzt kriegen, wir müssen den nächsten zwei Tagen. Sorry, der hat keinen Einfluss darauf, wann dieser syrische Spion am Dia, dass der genau am Dia dem erhebt hat. Doch klar, als ob James Bond nicht sagen würde, okay, pass auf, mir ist klar, dass es dringend ist, aber in der Woche, pass auf, ne, hör mal zu, in der Woche ist Diaz de la Tho Mendo. Da kann ich gar nicht, weil ich liebe Diaz de la Tho Mendo. Einerseits kann ich nicht, andererseits, wir können auch aus zwei Minussen ein Plus machen, pass auf, pass auf, bleib da. Diese Masken sind halt schon geil. Wenn ich die trage, dann sehen die nicht, dass ich James Bond bin. Verstehst du, weil die Filme haben tatsächlich meiner Geheimhaltung doch ein bisschen geschadet und dann könnte ich so tun, als wäre ich so ein Skelettmann und dann gehe ich da rein und dann sagen die, oh, ist ein normaler Skelettmann, dann sage ich Ping, Ping, Ping. Viel wichtiger finde ich die Frage, James. Warum legst du dein Date genau auf den Tag, wo sowohl Diadiol of Mere is, als auch der syrische Flüchtlinge, den du umbringen musst? Warum musst du an dem Tag, zieh es alleine durch, warum brauchst du da auch noch, warum bist du betrunken an dem Tag mal wieder und warum legst du ausgerechnet auch dein Date dahin? Hey, als ich hier angefangen habe, habe ich gesagt, ich bin der beste Spür in der Welt, aber ich will 364 Urlaubstage, Okay, und was hast du damals gesagt? Was hast du damals gesagt? Ich habe Hunger, ich weiß nicht, was ich gesagt habe. Genau, und deswegen bin ich hier. Sehr gut. James Bond ist, magst du James Bond, bist du großer James Bond-Fan? Ja, also ich fand jetzt Spectre nicht mehr so gut, aber Skyfall hat mich einfach richtig abgeholt, fand ich richtig gut. Super Film. Aber vor allem, ich frage mich immer so, man hat ja immer so das Gefühl bei so Filmen, dass das so epische Geschichten sind und die verändern die ganze Welt und am Ende geht die Welt kaputt oder nicht. Aber teilweise sind die ja in der Spielzeit total kurz, so ist ein Nachmittag. Also so der gesamte, ich grüße jetzt bei Skyfall nicht, aber so bei Mission Impossible ist ein guter Nachmittag. Ist so gut, ist so 14 bis 18 Uhr. Das ist die gesamte Plot. Die meisten kriegen nichts davon mit. Ich finde geil mit. Ich finde geil, wenn man mal so eine B-Story erzählen würde von irgendeinem Typen, der einfach in der Zeit nur eine Tätigkeit macht. Halt sein Haus wischen oder so. Oder so am Anfang des Tages siehst du, wie der seinen Nudelshop aufmacht und dann siehst du am Ende des Films, wie der in die Mittagspause geht. Und für den war das einfach nur eine Frühschicht. Und für uns und Tom Cruise
ist alles passiert. Übrigens, Busted.
Ach so, ich dachte, dass ganz am Ende dann,
bei dem der Nudeljob kaputt gemacht wird.
Ausgerechnet davor. Ja, jetzt aber, jetzt denkst du wie ein Drehbuchautor.
Also jetzt hast du wieder...
Sorry, tut mir leid. Ja, okay,
mir ist da, dass du dich verändert hast.
Oh, tut mir leid, seit ich den Schuh Hamburg preis...
Ja, ja, ja. Versuche ich mal ein geniales
Gedächtnis auszuschalten. Okay, zieh die Hose dann, ist okay. Ist kein Problem. Aber tatsächlich, du wurdest gebastet. Was? Denn du hast dir die Theorie aufgestellt. Oh, wir sind jetzt übrigens in der Rubrik. Wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, back, back, back. Du hast nämlich behauptet, dass alle berühmten Actionstars und Action-Schauspieler alle besonders klein sind, weil da anscheinend die Körperproportionen richtig sind. Und direkt, weißt du, ruf immer auf, wir haben letztes Mal aufgerufen, Leute, bitte spendet für dicke Kinder. Hat das schon jemand die Liste bereit mit Actionheldenstars über 1,90? Ja, natürlich. Ja, ja. Und wir haben letztes, vor zwei Monaten haben wir aufgerufen, spendet für dicke Kinder. Wisst ihr, wie viel Geld reinkam? Ein halbes Snickers kam rein, sonst gar nichts. Und dann sagen wir einmal, stellst du eine Theorie auf und schon hunderttausende, das Mailfach läuft heiß. Warum kriegst du den ganzen Hass, den du, den dich betrifft, ich immer? Ey, du willst die Mails nicht lesen, du willst wirklich, ich tue dir was Gutes, indem ich die Filter, indem ich nämlich die 200 Mails, vielen Dank an alle, die geschrieben haben, Keanu Reeves ist 1,84 groß oder sowas. Ja, ist er. Und Stefan Bastet. Ich habe noch nie so viele Stefan Bastet im Betreff gelesen wie in der Zeit. Aber vielen Dank nochmal für alle 200, die das bemerkt haben. Und Stefan somit komplett den Teppich unter den Füssen weggezogen haben. Ja, jetzt gib mal mal die Liste. Du kannst nicht einfach sagen. Es ging um die Liste, es ging um Keanu Reeves. Der ist 1,86. Ja, 1,86. Na gut, aber hier Tom Cruise 1,71, Sandra Bullock 1,71, Liam Neeson 1,93? Ja! So viel zum Nehmen bei Körperproportionen. Will Smith? Komm schon, Will Smith. Komm schon. Warum muss man Stefan Tietze eingibt, eigentlich das dritte immer Grösse? 1,88. Gut, die Theorie ist, Jaden Smith aber nur 1,74. Ja, das ist ein Kind. Dwayne The Rock Johnson, 1,96. Fällt dir was auf? Das sind recht normale Grösse, ne, in der Verteilung. Ich würde sogar sagen, überproportional groß. Überproportional groß, würde man schon sagen. Ja, ist busted. Wo wir gerade bei User-Einsendungen sind, wir haben natürlich auch eine Menge, tatsächlich, mir hat jemand geschrieben, dass wir mittlerweile, wir erobern die Akademie, ja, Justitia, Galores, ja, meine Alma Mater, die Universitas, ja, da, wo wir eigentlich ankommen wollen, wo man die Hüte in die Luft wirft, deswegen sind ja auch immer so hoch die Gebäude, weil man ja den Hut immer so hochwerfen will. Meine Taktik beim Abschluss war, den Hut möglichst weit wegzuwerfen, dass da niemand landet, dass ich meinen Hut wiederbekomme. Ich will doch nicht den Hut von einem Fremden. Wie so ein Frisbee einfach so. Und dann habe ich ausserdem den Vater getroffen, der gerade auf seine Kamera guckt, weil die SD keine Folge hat. Der krebskranke Vater, der noch mal reingerollt wird, weil seine Tochter graduiert und du zack, Kopf ab, einfach, Kopf ab. Wir haben ja letztens gesagt, genau, wir sind nämlich jetzt auch nicht nur in der Linguistik angekommen, nicht nur in der Soziologie, nicht nur irgendwie vom Amtsgericht Köln, nein, wir sind auch angekommen in den Theaterwissenschaften. Wirklich? Warum? In den Theaterwissenschaften hat anscheinend die Dozentin eines Hörers darüber gesprochen, über diese, man sagtagt-Dinge-nur-um-sie zu sagen. Warum kriegst du die ganzen Mails in der Ruhe? Warte, warte, warte, warte, warte. Hier hat jemand geschrieben, meine Dozentin erwähnte Stephans Zoo-Geschichte in einem Seminar über Analysemethoden der Theaterwissenschaft. Ganz kurz, was für eine Zoo-Gogeschichte. Ich bin häufig im Zoo, es gibt viele erzählen über Zoos. Welche Zoogeschichte? Wir haben in der letzten Woche zu 99% darüber geredet, dass du in einem Zoo warst. Ja, aber was habe ich da erzählt? Das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht mehr so genau. Also fast jeder Satz ging viral aus dieser Folge, weil du so viele tolle Gags gemacht hast über Hyänen. Ja, aber was und die Dozentin hört uns.
Entweder das, ich weiß nicht genau, aber auf jeden Fall hat er geschrieben, die Dozentin erwähnte Stephans Zoo-Geschichte, was ich schon mal gut finde. Ich meine, anscheinend ist Goethe nicht mehr genug an deutschen Unis, anscheinend gibt es keine Theaterstücke mehr, die analysiert werden. Es gibt Baltize-Seminare. Zwanghaft den Namen bei Tieren beim ersten Sehen auszusprechen, sei ein perfektes Beispiel für semiotisches Denken, das Lesen von Dingen als Zeichen mit fester Bedeutung. Ja, aber das ist doch trotzdem unangenehm. Das kann man jetzt schön beschreiben, das kann man jetzt irgendwie, das kann nett klingen, das kann man auch auf Latein sagen, trotzdem ist es super scheisse nervig. Aber es wurde angesprochen, semiotisches Denken hat Stefan hier vorgeführt. Und wir haben als Antwort auf den Aufruf ganz viele Nachrichten bekommen von euch, die auch Situationen geschickt haben, in denen man immer was sagen muss. Einerseits muss man sagen, zu guten 95 Prozent Thema verfehlt. Muss man einfach mal so sagen, da bin ich auch hart. Du bist ein unangenehmer Lehrer, der reinkommt, den man nicht haben will, bei dem man keine Klassenerarbeit schreiben muss. Oh nein, wir haben Herrn Will. Der kommt am Anfang immer rein und sagt, dass 98 Prozent das Thema verfehlt haben. Okay. Willst du das vortragen, hast du das zusammengestellt in der Top-40-Liste? So, und zwar hat jemand geschrieben, Standardwitze über die eigene Kaffee-Präferenz. Muss man immer verbalisieren, aufgrund dieser Person, die schreibt, schwarz wie meine Seele, blond und süss. Man muss also immer den Kaffee, den man macht, umschreiben. Genau, wie meine Frauen ohne Nüsse. Ja, genau. Ich mag meinen Kaffee wie meine Frauen in einer Tasse. Das sind dann immer die Gags, wo dann das ganze Büro lacht. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man einen Muskelkater hat, finde ich gut, schreibt Ken. Wenn man einen Muskelkater hat, muss man ansprechen. Da, finde ich, spielt mir aber noch zu viel Bedeutung mit rein. Weil wenn man einen Muskelkater anspricht, dann macht man das ja nicht einfach so, sondern dann will man zeigen, ich habe trainiert. Ich war gestern trainiert. Irgendwie, ich bin ein krasser Typ, auch wenn es jetzt gerade nicht so aussieht, ich bin ziemlich fähig, ich bin über meine Grenzen gegangen, das heißt, das hat für mich schon Sinn, das ist wie wenn du... Ich frage mich kurz, falls die Leute jetzt anfangen, uns zu hören, wir haben letzte Woche darüber gesprochen, dass man Dinge einfach verbalisieren muss. Genau. Beispiele waren, man geht zu einem Gehege und sagt, oh, das ist das Nashorn, obwohl alle sehen, dass das das Nashorn ist, es steht sogar geschrieben davor. Ja. Dein Beispiel war, es beginnt zu regnen. Undenkbar, dass eine Gruppe durch die Straße geht, es fängt an zu regnen und man stellt sich einfach unter, ohne das offene Problem anzusprechen. Oder mit Zwanziger die Grasgeruch riechen. Immer, da hat aber jemand einen Lütten angemacht, oder? Das ist immer unangenehm. Was tatsächlich häufig kam und was ich nicht so auf dem schirm hatte ist oder ist stau wenn man anscheinend in einer gruppe oder alleine auf einen autobahn stau oder ein sonstiges stau zufährt das stimmt oder ist stau was ich sehr lustig fand was ich wo ich sehr relaten konnte war das typische eichhörnchen oder ist ein eichhörnchen ja das muss man verbalisieren weil und man muss sagen eichhörnchen sind nicht selten in deutschland Man sieht Eichhörnchen oder ist ein Eichhörnchen. Das muss man verbalisieren, weil, und man muss sagen, Eichhörnchen sind nicht selten in Deutschland. Man sieht Eichhörnchen relativ häufig. Warum ist es denn immer so ein Ding? Also gerade bei uns in der Schulklasse, war es immer so ein Running Gag, dass man einfach, man will nicht Herrn Reiner Rembrandt zuhören, sondern man will rüber gucken zum Eichhörnchen. Man muss verbalisieren, Leute, da ist es spannend da gerade. Ja, und man muss es auch entschuldigen, dass man nicht gedankenlos aus dem Fenster starrt, sondern sagt, da war ein Eichhörnchen. Und dann sagt der Lehrer, gut, gut, danke, bist entschuldig. Geht nochmal durch. Super fand ich auch, Heissluftballon. Ja, das stimmt tatsächlich. Zeppelin, Heissluftballon, komische Objekte am Himmel müssen verbalisiert werden. Vor allem, also Heissluftballon ist ja eine Sache. Aber jetzt lassen wir ganz kurz über Zeppeline reden. Holy shit, wow. Nicht mehr so häufig zu sehen. Zeppelin? Aber wusstest du, dass das Zeppelin-Werk nur aus einem Grund, wegen einer Tierart noch da ist, noch existiert? Weil niemand braucht mehr Zeppeline. Ja. Zeppeline waren mal cool, weil du langsam fliegen konntest. Quasi wurde ja durch den Helikopter gewissermaßen ein bisschen obsolet. Die Konzeption eines ... Früher hatte ADAC Zeppeline. Genau, ist mit Zeppeline zum Auto gekommen, hat ihn abgeschleppt. Auch Schwerkranke wurden, wenn die mit einem Skiunfall, wurden mit Zeppeline abgeholt. Dann sind sie aber leider gestorben, weil Zeppeline zu langsam sind. Das stimmt. Man kennt das alles. Und leider anfängt zu brennen, sobald sie. Ah, sobald sie anfängt zu brennen, auch unangenehm. Dann versucht man mit der Concorde, die ist dann auch schiefgegangen. Hat es auch mal mit Löschzeppelin versucht, das war ein Riesenschuss in den Ofen. Ganz, ganz, ganz doofe Sache. Und dann kam der Helikopter, der wesentlich besser ist, aber jetzt gibt es eine Affenart, die erforscht werden muss, irgendwo im Amazonas. Und diese Affenart, die kann natürlich ganz nicht mit dem Helikopter kommen, dann sagt die Affenart, was ist das für ein Geräusch, tschüss, ich bin weg hier. Deswegen muss, dafür braucht man Zeppeline, spezielle Forschungszeppeline. Ja, aber kannst du eine Drohne nehmen oder so? Nein. Die sind auch laut. Ja. Ja, aber diese Flugdrohnen, also die die Amerikaner. Zu laut, Affen sagen nö, nö, nö, nö, nö. Drohnen sind doch nicht laut. Die sind empfindlich, deswegen kommt man damit Zeppeline an, die exakt kein Geräusch machen. Ja, damit die Affen das nicht merken, wenn es dunkel wird. Die verdunkeln den Himmel, aber machen kein Geräusch. Das sind Affen ja egal. Weißen, blinde Affen, Arzt, die besonders tolle, große Ohren haben. Ich dachte jetzt... Aber deswegen existiert die Firma noch. Zeppelin am Bodensee ist eine Firma. Gibt es noch an die Zeppelin-Universität und diese Firma existiert, glaube ich. Kommt wieder mit euren Mails, kommt mit Stefan Bastet nächste Woche. Aber ich glaube, die gibt es nur deswegen. Ich dachte, du, als du jetzt gesagt hast, es gibt wegen einer seltenen Tierart, dass in der Zeppelin-Werft, in dem Zeppelin-Hangar, dass da in dem Gebäude eine seltene Vogelart lebt, wo man dies deswegen nicht abreißen darf. Ach so, oder die gespendet haben für den verbleibten Zeppelin-Werkes. Ja, genau. Ein Tierart liebt Zeppelin. Daniel schreibt auf Twitter, das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, das fällt leider nicht so ganz unter die Kategorie, ist aber durchaus richtig, wenn der Schaffner sich im Zug bei der Ansage verspricht oder verhaspelt, müssen dazu Kommentare gemacht werden. Ich weiß, auch ich, ah, das sind diese Dinge, wo man das hasst, dass man Mensch ist, dass man doch nur ist wie jeder andere. Aber das würde ich jetzt eher so unter Gag-Touret oder sowas sam sammeln. Das ist nicht dasselbe, wie man muss was verbalisieren, weil das ist ja so ein, man macht es noch als Gag, man macht es als Reaktion auf was. Es ist ja schon irgendeine Form von, es kann als kreative Leistung verstanden werden. Es kann als Gag verstanden werden, wohingegen oh Leute, es regnet, oh jetzt zieht es aber zu. Das kann man ja nicht mal als Kreativität verstehen. Dass Leute gackig auf was reagieren, ist ja durchaus angemessen und legitim. Aber deswegen passt für mich das nicht ganz rein. Aber es stimmt als Punkt. Es muss immer kommentiert werden. Und ist auch immer ein Lacher. Was mir voll gefällt ist Regenbogen. Natürlich, man muss den Regenbogen ansprechen. Ich habe auch immer noch nicht ganz genau, weil Licht gebrochen wird, man kann das spielen. Ja, das sind so Dinge, die man so zu 30 Prozent versteht. Können wir auch mal drüber reden, Dinge, die man so zu 30 Prozent versteht. Der Regenbogen, klar, es gibt so Dinge, die versteht man so weit, dass man sie seinem Kind erklären könnte. Aber auch nicht in der Öffentlichkeit. Wenn ein Kind in der U-Bahn fragt, willst du es ihm nicht erklären? Es sei denn, die U-Bahn ist plötzlich sehr laut. Das sind die schönsten Momente, wenn so ein Kind seinen Vater fragt, Papa, was ist Inflation? Und der ganze Zug, ja, Papa, was ist Ininflation? Das ist, wenn dein Teddybär, also wenn der ganz viel Fail noch im, im, im, im, im. Guck mal, ein Eichhörnchen. Es ist einfach, es funktioniert nicht. Aber das ist eigentlich der einzige Grund, warum man Sachen lernt, um sie seinen Kindern zu erklären. Weil man muss ja nur so zwei, drei Sätze rauskriegen. Dann verlieren Kinder das Interesse. Die sagen ja nicht, jetzt, Entschuldigung, jetzt noch mal ganz kurz, Herr Vater,
wenn jetzt aber das Licht sich bricht,
also das wird
durch die Atmosphäre gebrochen sozusagen,
warum sieht man das denn an einem statischen Ort,
warum sieht man das dann nicht zum Beispiel an der anderen Seite?
Keine Rückfragen,
Kinder stellen keine Rückfragen,
auch keine kritischen Gegenfragen.
Naja, wenn, dann fragen sie nur, warum, warum,
warum, aber da kannst du ja dann sagen, ja, weil Physik, weil Einstein. Genau. dann fragen sie nur, warum, warum, warum. Aber da kannst du ja dann sagen, ja, weil Physik, weil Einstein.
Genau.
Sie fragen entweder, warum, warum, warum, oder sie verlieren das Interesse.
Mein Tipp deswegen, einfach schwafeln.
Lange schwafeln, bis man zum Punkt kommt, den man dann nicht mehr weiß.
Na, das Kind oft ist Interesse verloren, weil interessantere Dinge in der U-Bahn passieren als Inflation.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ja, aber das ist schon interessant. Kinder sind da sehr offenbar und schnell das Problem, eine beendete Bildungslücke. Du, Papa, warum sind Wale so gross? Weil die Evolution, man muss sich ja vorstellen, dass im Wasser, man wiegt ja nicht so viel im Wasser, weil Wasser trägt ja auch, ist ja eine Masse, die... Und deswegen hat die Evolution gesagt, wenn grosse Tiere, dann im Wasser.
Weil...
Oh, Papa hat glaube ich, Papa hat so ein Stechen in der Brust.
Oh nein, nicht Papa!
Hat schon wieder so ein Stechen wie damals, als du mich gefragt hast, was Inflation ist.
Hat Papa so ein Stechen, weißt du, was du dann gemacht hast, was du dann machen solltest?
Warum? Dann solltest du nämlich Mama anrufen. Okay. Und du rennst dann um Hilfe schreien. Der nächste halt, Köln Hauptbahnhof. Ah, der hat sich versprochen. Und was auch tatsächlich sehr oft kam von verschiedenen Einsendungen, ich nenne jetzt mal Kevin stellvertretend, der hat geschrieben, wenn man in eine Lokalität zum Beispiel kommt, die voll ist und man sagt, oh, ist aber voll hier. Auch hier möchte ich Einspruch erheben, denn hier hat die Aussage durchaus eine Bedeutung, denn in meiner Meinung nach ist, oh, das ist hier aber voll, ist ein verdeckter, ich will hier nicht sein. Lass uns woanders hingehen. Ich hasse solche Menschen und das sind nämlich Leute, die nicht Bock haben, gerade den ganzen Prozess zu beschleunigen. Wenn ihr sagt, oh, ist aber voll hier, und ihr damit sagen wollt, es ist mir hier zu voll, können wir bitte weitergehen, seid ihr der Bremswagen des Zuges der Gesellschaft. Und sorry, das macht es für mich kompliziert. Ihr seid jetzt zwei Euro Stück auf den Gleisen der Menschheit. Genau, wie mich neulich jemand eine Kollegin gefragt hat, liebe Grüße an der Stelle, sie hat mich gefragt, wollen wir vielleicht die Tür zumachen? Das ist nicht das, was du sagen willst. Du willst sagen, kannst du bitte die Tür zumachen? Klar, ich habe keine Lust, wenn du sagst, nein, ich will es unbedingt nicht. Natürlich ist das keine Frage, sie will, dass die Tür zu ist. Wenn sie sich dabei auch noch so lasziv den Schal umlegt, weil es ihr zu kalt ist offensichtlich,
können wir bitte das Fenster zumachen?
Das verstehe ich schon eher.
Aber es ist doch eher, kannst du bitte das Fenster zumachen,
mir ist es zu kalt.
Immer dieses Verpackt als Frage, um den Konsens der Gruppe zu suchen,
gefällt mir nicht.
Ich muss dir da widersprechen, ich bin ein großer Fan davon,
Dinge als solche zu verpacken.
Weil es muss schon sein, weil du machst die Stimmung nicht schlecht.
Weil angenommen, du kommst jetzt zu fünft in ein Restaurant und einer sagt, oh, es ist aber ganz schön voll hier, oder? Dann hast du als Gruppe noch die Möglichkeit, trotzdem dort zu essen, ohne dass die Stimmung schlecht ist. Wo führt einen denn dieser basisdemokratische Scheiss hin? Nee, nee, nee, ohne dass die Stimmung schlecht ist. Wenn man zu fünft in ein Restaurant kommt und jemand sagt, oh, ich finde es hier nicht so geil, ich finde es stinkt hier, können wir woanders hingehen? Und dann sagen die anderen vier, aber nee, ich würde hier gerne schon essen. Dann ist die Stimmung schlecht, weil man dann weiß, dass eine Person nicht da sein möchte. Ja, wenn die eine Person sagt, oh, es ist aber ziemlich voll hier, oder? Dann weiß man doch auch, wenn alle sagen, nö, finde ich nicht, und dann reingehen, dass diese Person auch den Abend nicht mehr glücklich wird. Naja, aber dann kann man zumindest so tun, als wäre gute Stimmung da. Und dann kann auch die andere Person, muss jetzt nicht irgendwie, oh, ich bin hier gegen meinen Willen, sondern man kann sagen, oh, ist ganz schön voll hier und dann sagt man, nee, nee, da hinten ist noch ein Platz und alle haben verstanden, was los ist und können so tun und können noch sagen, ah, wir sind hier und der einzige Beschwerdegrund war die Platzprobleme, aber war es natürlich nicht, aber man kann so tun, als wäre das derzeitige Grund. Meine Liste der unangenehmen Menschen wurde gerade, also die Leute, die fragen, ist aber voll hier oder, sind gerade auf Platz zwei gerutscht. Noch unangenehmer sind die, die dann sagen, nö, da ist aber noch ein freier Platz. Ja. Weil die offensichtlich im Scheiss geben. Ja, die Person hat es entweder nicht verstanden und nimmt es wörtlich oder sie hat es genau verstanden und sagt, nee, ich will hier auf jeden Fall essen. Ich will aber nicht, dass die Stimmung so schlecht ist, indem ich sage, nee, ich will hier essen, auch wenn du denkst, dass es hier stinkt. Und deswegen sind ... Also, wenn beide soziale Schach spielen, dann läuft's. Das Problem ist immer nur, wenn einer soziale Schach spielt, der andere nicht. Der sagt, ich hab gerade gar nicht verstanden den Subtext, da hinten ist ein freier Tisch, und da sitz ich heute Abend und stopfe meinen Mund voll. Naja, aber du möchtest jetzt angenommen, du möchtest jetzt in dem Restaurant nicht essen, du bist jetzt aber auch nicht so abgeneigt, dass du sagst, ich will jetzt hier ein Veto einlegen. Sondern du sagst, ich möchte in der Gruppe, dass bemerkt wird, dass ich gegen dieses Lokal bin. Ich wäre jetzt aber auch nicht komplett abgeneigt, wenn alle anderen der Meinung sind. Ich will mich der Mehrheitsmeinung nicht versperren. Und diese Botschaft kannst du nur überbringen mit, oh, ist aber ganz schön voll hier. Weil dann kannst du immer noch als Gruppe dort essen und in der Illusion leben, dass alle irgendwie Bock hatten, weil du ja nur das pragmatische Argument entkräften musst. Nee, das funktioniert schon. Ich verstehe es, ich finde, dass die Gesellschaft aber nicht so richtig, nein, man trainiert sich nämlich einfach ab, teilweise zu sagen, was wirklich Sache ist. Man gewöhnt sich so ein subtiles Geschwafel an, wo niemand mehr genau weiß, ob das jetzt Gesellschaftsschach ist oder einfach eine ernst gemeinte Frage ist. Ich finde, manchmal müssen Dinge ausgesprochen werden. Auch der offen ausgetragende Konflikt zwischen der eine findet es sehr voll, der andere findet es okay, hat ja auch gewisse Spannungspotenzial für einen schönen Abend. Nee, eben nicht für einen schönen Abend, weil dann steht es zu konkret im Raum. Ja, es sei denn, man geht allemal einen Schritt zurück und entspannt sich und betrachtet das Leben als etwas Schönes, was Lebenswertes. Und dann sagt man, okay, hier ist heute Abend voll, es ist ein Abend, aber es ist doch nicht schlimm. Man kann doch trotzdem einen schönen Abend haben in einem vollen Restaurant. Du musst ja den Abend nicht versauen lassen. Ich finde, man kann das durchaus ernsthaft aussprechen. Aber was jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn eine Person vielleicht nicht so viel Geld hat wie die anderen und bemerkt, oh, das Restaurant ist für mich zu teuer. So hat man die Möglichkeit, durch soziales Schach kann sie sagen, oh, ist aber ganz schön voll hier. Oder ist ja ganz schön laut hier. Oder irgendwas anderes zu sagen und alle anderen checken, okay, ich steige darauf ein oder nicht. Ja, wie gesagt, trotzdem wäre die Person, die dann sagt, da hinten ist aber ein leerer Tisch frei, einfach ein höchster Haarsch von der Gruppe. Völlig richtig. Bist du eher ein Leader oder ein Follower in der Gruppe? Ich bin ein Follower, aber es macht es einem auch manchmal nicht so leicht, weil das eigentliche Problem ist nur, wenn niemand leadet, dann sage ich manchmal schon, okay, jetzt nehme ich es in die Hand, aber... Ja, weil oft, wenn jemand fragt, hier ist aber voll, oder, dann oft wird es einen Satz, dass alle merken, okay, hier schwingt was mit, hier gefallen der Person Dinge nicht, dass dann sowas passiert wie, ja, weiß ich nicht, wir können auch woanders hingehen, ja, weiß ich nicht, der andere will subtil miteinander doch gerne da reingehen würde und es kommt zu einem Stillstand. Ja. Und dann steht man davor und dann lässt man Leute, dann muss man zur Seite gehen, dann kommen Leute vor, drücken sich dann durch. Ich bin der, der seinen eigenen Willen gnadenlos unterordnet. Ich bin der, dem der Kompromiss viel wichtiger ist als die eigene Meinung, der sagt, wenn man sich nicht einigen kann, dann bin ich der Erste, der zurücksteckt, der sagt, gut, dann essen wir halt Kram. Aber wir sind ja sozial, wir sind nicht die sozialsten Menschen, die ich kenne, ehrlich gesagt. Wir gehen jetzt nicht so häufig abends in Gruppen raus. Liegt es daran, weil wir unseren Willen immer gnadenlos unterordnen oder ordnen wir unseren Willen gnadenlos unter, weil wir sozial nicht so richtig kompatibel sind? Weil das ist ja ein Grund, demnach, wenn du deinen Willen immer unterordnest, hast du ja per Definition nie den Abend, den du dir vorstellst. Nee, ich glaube, du wirst pedantischer, je häufiger du etwas tust und je grösser der Teil, das dein Leben einnimmt. Also angenommen, du gehst jetzt jeden Tag in ein Restaurant, dann ist es ein großer Teil deiner Lebenszeit. Und dann ist es ja auch verständlich, wenn du den Anspruch hast, ich will nur in Restaurants gehen, die ich auch persönlich mag. Man kann auch sagen, wie wir jetzt die einmal im Monat im Restaurant gehen. Aber der One-Shot muss sitzen. Nee, das finde ich eben nicht. Findest du nicht? Wenn du einmal in deinem Leben im Restaurant pro Monat, dann sagst du, mir ist es völlig egal, weil das nimmt nicht so einen grossen Teil meines Lebens an. Aber du hast einmal im Jahr Geburtstag und es soll trotzdem der beste Tag des Jahres werden. Ja, na, zum Geburtstag. Wenn du zum Beispiel häufig ins Kino gehst, wirst du immer pedantischer, weil du einfach, das ist ein grösserer Teil des Lebens wird, als wenn du jetzt einmal sagst, ja, ich kenne mich eh nicht aus, ich weiß eh nicht, was möglich ist. Ich bin so oft im Kino, mir ist es scheißegal, ob dieser eine Abend ein bisschen, außer wenn es sich gerade der neue Batman im Kino ist, mir ist es mir doch scheißegal. Weiß ich nicht. Zum Beispiel jemand, der viel Musik hört, legt Wert auf hochwertige Lautsprecher. Weil er, da dieses Hobby einen grossen Teil seines deiner Freizeit einnimmt, bereit ist, da mehr Energie zu investieren, damit sich das lohnt. Wohingegen jemand, der nur Radio geplappert im Hintergrund hört, dem ist es nicht so wichtig. Und ich glaube, dieses Prinzip kann man auch auf soziale Sachen überlagern, dass man mehr Energie reinsetzt, wenn es einen grossen Teil ist und nicht weniger. Das stimmt. Marcel schreibt, und das kann ich überhaupt nicht mit anfangen, man kommt mit einer Gruppe in einen Bus- oder Strassenbahnhaltestelle mit digitaler Anzeige ein. Einer muss immer die noch verbleibende Zeit aussprechen. Ah, noch vier Minuten. Ist mir noch nie vorgekommen, Marcel. Passiert das? Noch nie. Man lebt in einem sehr konkreten Freundeskreis. Das ist nämlich der Tod von Comedians. In Freundeskreisen zu leben, wo bestimmte Dinge gemacht werden, die sonst nicht mehr gemacht werden. Man steht ja auf der Bühne und sagt, dass man immer die Digitalanzeige anspricht. Stille. Es tut es tut mir leid, dass Marcel noch nicht abgehoben ist als Stand-Up-Act, aber das liegt nicht an ihm. Er ist lustig, es liegt an seinen scheiß Freunden. Genau. Und deswegen glaube ich, können auch, also Insider sind der Tod von Comedians. Klar. Ja, vor allem Insider, die sich nicht als Insider präsentieren. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie Fussball schaust, dann weißt du, oder wenn du jetzt halt irgendwie Formel 1 schaust, dann weißt du, dass das, was du da weißt, nicht jeder weiss, aber so soziale Dinge geht man davon aus, dass jeder weiss. Aber tatsächlich ist es ja auch interessant, weil man kommt ja manchmal in andere soziale Gruppen und merkt dann, oh, da sind ganz andere Dinge gängig. Ich erinnere mich, das habe ich schon mal erzählt, dass ich mit einem Freund von mir bei ihm zu Hause mit seiner Familie Schules Manitur geschaut habe. So, und dann gibt es ja diese eine... Das heißt, du hast gesagt, wir gucken einen Film heute Abend bei dir, und du bist davon ausgegangen, dass ihr zu zweit einen schönen romantischen Abend habt, wo man euch irgendwie die Füsse gegenseitig lackiert und dann halt mit einer Decke... Und dann kam Tante Erna. Und dann kam Tante Erna und der Hund der Familie. Rupert, der Neffe, Piepsi, der Vogel, alle waren da. Piepsi, der Vater, alle waren da. Und dann schaut man diesen Film an und da gibt es ja diese eine Szene, wo die auf Indianisch reden. Und ich glaube dann irgendwie ist auch so Rauchzeichen und dann steht der Untertitel. Ist das echtes Indianisch? Und dann steht der Untertitel dran. Und mein Freund, wie völlig selbstverständlich, liest diese Untertitel laut vor. Das ist nicht dein Ernst, das hat er noch nie erzählt. Wie lustig ist das? Während das passiert, liest er diese Untertitel laut vor, in einem Raum voller Menschen, die lesen können. So ein lustiges Selbstexperiment. Ja, aber vor allem auch nichts, aber wirklich von der ersten Sekunde an, so no bullshit, das macht man jetzt.
Und ich dachte mir wirklich, macht man das so? Habe ich das mein Leben lang falsch gemacht? Bei mir hat das noch nie jemand gemacht. Und ich dachte mir so, also entweder ist er völlig wahnsinnig oder ich bin falsch aufgewachsen. Aber später durch mehr Erfahrung stelle ich sich raus, nee, der Typ ist einfach nur komplett bescheuert. Und das ist schon erstaunlich, einfach. Aber das ist so eine gewisse Form
von Selbstbewusstsein. Das ist meine
große Theorie, du musst Dinge selbstbewusst machen,
und schon wirken die wie Selbstverständlich.
Genau. Weil, angenommen, du würdest
im Kino sitzen und die
Produktionslogos der Firmen einmal
laut sagen, ja,
20th Century Fox,
Ambient Films,
und das wäre das normal.
Dolby Surround.
Dann würden wir auch zu dir gucken und sagen ...
Nee, warte, das fängt erst dissonant an und wird dann zu einem Ton.
Achtung, wir machen's.
Ähm ...
Perfekt.
Das THX-Logo.
Was ist deine grösste soziale Angst?
Ich habe herausgefunden, und ich gebe dir ein bisschen Zeit zu überlegen.
Danke, damit mein Versagen dann noch inkomitenter wird.
Damit das Story noch ein bisschen besser wird und der ganze Content ein bisschen geiler. Geil. Meine grösste soziale Angst ist es, das habe ich jetzt wieder gemerkt, Die Menschen sind die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, ja. Es gibt nichts Schlimmeres auf der ganzen Welt, außer bei einer Polonaise vorne stehen. Ja, so viel Verantwortung kann niemand tragen. Beides ist zu viel Verantwortung. Und vor allem, man muss sich ja irgendwie auch auf Verantwortung, musst du dich vorbereiten. Du musst dann irgendwie sagen, okay, jetzt schaffe ich es, du musst vom Spiel stehen, das Proben, ob es eine Rede auf der Hochzeit ist, keine Ahnung. Du bereitest dich ja auf gewisse Verantwortungspositionen vor. Bei sowas kannst du das ja nicht, weil es ja spontan kommt. Du planst nicht, dass du der Anfang einer Polonaise bist. Du planst nicht, dass der Ball genau auf dich fliegt. Und dann ist die Frage, schießt man jetzt rüber, will man besonders cool sein, nimmt man ihn in die Hand, wirft man ihn rüber und droht dann, dass der Ball wieder am Zaun abspringt und wieder zu dir kommt. Man weiß es nicht. Das stimmt schon. Fussball ist ja auch noch okay, aber das Allerschlimmste sind Frisbees. Oh Gott! Weil kein Mensch der Welt kann Frisbee werfen. Ja, vor allem, du bist ja auch nicht drin. Du bist auch nicht drin. Der erste Frisbee-Wurf geht immer komplett. Selbst diese Ultimate-Frisbee-Spieler. Geradeaus hat er auch 90 Grad Winkel links. Und ich frage, wie kann das denn jetzt sein? Ja, also du wirfst ihn und es sieht gut aus und es sieht gut aus und wir rufen Leute, man will der Frisbee sagen, es gibt noch sowas wie Gravitation und physikalische Gesetze. Der Fakt, dass du jetzt 90 Grad nach links abgebogen bist, kann nicht sein.
Ja, vor allem, ich meine, das hat ja selbst Einstein gesagt, Gravitation ist da im C-Quadrat, ausser Frisbees, in der Klammer. Ausser Frisbees. Ja, aber da fällt mir die vielleicht lustigste Geschichte meines Lebens ein. Wow, wow. Das ist unfassbar. Und zwar haben wir Fussball spielen, Kinder spielen Fussball, man spielt Fussball und wir haben in einem Dorf gebunden, wo es relativ viele freie Flächen gab, aber es gab einen Fussballplatz, der war auch so ein bisschen an einer viel befahrenen Strasse, also nicht so mega viel, aber einer. Und dann hat ein Kind einfach überfahren. Oh mein Gott, hilarious. Und dann hatten wir nur noch sieben Spieler und dann musste immer der Dicke draußen warten. Letzter Held. Und dann spielt man den Hals und dann ist der Ball manchmal so auf die Strasse geflogen. Und wenn halt da gerade Autos waren, war es halt so ein bisschen gefährlich, weil man kann dann auch irgendwie die Autos weichen aus oder die Autos machen dann so den Autoball-Move und mit dem Heck dann so Dots. Ja und so. Und dann überarbeiten sich. So ist Stefan Rabe auf die Idee gekommen für Autoball. Ja und einmal fliegt der Ball der Ball direkt auf die Straße und bleibt auf der Straße liegen. Das muss er erst mal schaffen, das ist gar nicht so leicht. Bleibt auf der Straße liegen, wir gehen an den Straßenrand und entfernen die Autos recht schnell. Und man guckt halt so, ah, wann kommt der, war keine Ampel in der Nähe. Und plötzlich bleibt ein Auto stehen, direkt neben dem Fußball. Und wir denken, ah, okay, gut, spielt jetzt den Ball zurück zurück, bleibt direkt neben dem Auto stehen, Tür geht auf, der Fahrer nimmt den Ball in das Auto, schließt die Tür und fährt weiter. What? Alle stehen da und so. Ich will die Geschichte von diesem Mann wissen. Okay, Playtime's over, einfach so, jetzt gehen wir zu Hause, der einzige Ball, der dabei war. Das kann ich so nachvollziehen, weil auch mein Gedanke war, wenn der Ball rüber, und als der Ball rüber geflogen ist, ich nehme den jetzt einfach mit, dann bin ich das Arschloch, aber ich bin ein cooles Arschloch. Also, mein Coolness-Status bleibt unverändert. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine Geste, die verdammten Kinder machen Strasseverkehr und dann wollte er uns eine Lehre zeigen, indem er den Ball wegnimmt und er dachte einfach, er hat den gefunden auf der Strasse? Ich finde das ein Megafilmanfang, weil es so viel charakterisiert diese Figur sehr. Aber man weist doch nicht genau, was das für eine Figur ist. Ja, aber geht der Film jetzt bei dem Kind weiter oder bei dem Autofahrer? Also die ganze Title Sequence, die ganzen Produktionslogos, die ganzen Namen der Schauspieler laufen über dem Fussballspiel, dann fliegt der Ball rüber, er hat auf der Strasse liegen, dann kommt das Auto an, hält daneben, Kinder freuen sich, okay, er schießt uns rüber, nimmt den Ball ins Auto und fährt nach Hause zu einer krebskranken Frau und diesen Film würde ich mir angucken. Lass uns ab jetzt immer eine weitere Minute des Films machen. Jeder Podcast? Jeder Podcast eine Minute. Das war jetzt heute die erste Minute. Die Opening Sequence, Musik, irgendwie, keine Ahnung was von den Smiths. Und ihr müsst sagen, was das Genre ist. Ich will euch in die Richtung denken. Mit Krebskrank hast du schon, also es wird kein Science Sci-Fi mehr, glaube ich, oder? Naja. Könnte noch Horror werden. Das ist heute mal die erste Minute. Und Stück für Stück und neun 80 Folgen haben wir ein komplettes Skript.
Okay, aber ich schreib das doch in Final Draft auf.
Ich schreib's in das Stream-Reiling-Programm und schreib's da rein.
Wir haben dann den Text.
In neun 80 Folgen haben wir ein komplettes Skript.
Das schicken wir an den Konstantin-Film.
Und so einfach so, mit so einem Riegel dazu,
mit so einem Kinderriegel dazu, Zwinker-Smiley so,
lest's euch mal durch.
Und vielleicht könnt ihr live mit dabei sein, wie der neue deutsche Hit entsteht.
Aber ich finde das sehr gut.
Früher gab es da wirklich, ich glaube in den 70er, 80er Jahren gab es da teilweise in Hollywood,
da sind wirklich so Bieterkämpfe um Drehbücher.
Also es gab wirklich einfach sehr viele Drehbuchautoren und sehr viel Bedarf an Filmen. Und es gab sehr viel Geld, die Produktsfilme hatten einfach sehr viel Geld. Und dadurch ist dann so ein komischer Kampf entstanden, es gab immer mehr Autoren, dann gab es wieder plötzlich mehr Produktionsfirmen und sehr viel Geld ist hin und her geflossen. Und haben die Autoren irgendwann gesagt, irgendwie war das dann so gang und gäbe, dass man strange Pitches vorbereitet hat und hat man nicht mehr die Skripte hat man nicht einfach mal abgegeben, sondern man hat die, wenn es irgendwie um einen Ölfilm von einer Ölplattform ging, hat man einen Ölfass gekauft, hat das Skript reingelegt und es dann ab und dann vor den Produktionen aus der Masse rausstecken. Richtig, und hat es dann davor abgestellt. Wo ist das bitte? Wahrscheinlich, weil sich da nicht die Besten durchsetzen, oder? Weil nicht der beste Pitcher der beste Autor ist. Genau. Da gibt es ja auch manchmal so Nine-Gag oder so Bilder so, oh, hier meine kreative Bewerbung und einer hat irgendwie einfach so eine Sechserpackung Donuts und hat oben in den Deckel so seine Bewerbung reingeschrieben und die Leute essen halt Donuts und haben direkt ein gutes Gefühl und stellen ihn ein. Völlig egal, ob der jetzt was gut ist oder nicht. Aber die Leute haben Donuts. Das ist viel besser. Weit dem Donuts. Donuts. Wie sagst du das zum Thema Donut mit Füllung? Weil bei Dunkin Donuts ist es ja so, dass die Donuts, die eine Füllung haben, haben kein Loch. Bitte was? Und jetzt denke ich mir, gut, das ist jetzt... Moment, ist das was Binäres? Ja, ja. Entweder Donut mit Loch oder Füllung Donut. Und da denke ich mir jetzt, du hast ein Problem mit einem weiteren Problem gelöst. Da ist es nichts gewonnen, weil du kannst nicht einen Donut füllen, indem du ihn nicht seine Donuthaftigkeit auflöst. Ich kann es natürlich verstehen, jetzt aus einem einem, sagen wir mal, Genusskonzept zu sagen, da passt dann mehr Füllung rein. Aber weißt du was, mein Kindheitstraum war die Homer Simpsons Donutbox, wo es dann den mit Himbeerfüllung gab, wo der dann reinbeißt und dann sieht man innerhalb des Donuts diesen roten Punkt und man weiß, in dem ganzen Donut ist rundherum ein Ring aus Himbeeren. Können wir kurz über Comic-Essen sprechen? Alter, es sieht immer besser aus. Wie lecker bei Asterix immer das Wildschwein war. Holy Crap! Und vor allem am Ende des Films. Die Henkelsteine. Am Ende des Films, wo du denkst, okay, es ist jetzt 21.30 Uhr, ich muss ins Bett, aber du hast gerade dieses saftige Wildschwein gesehen und du gehst hungrig ins Bett machen. Brot. Brot. Ja, oh ja. Das ist wirklich Irre. Auch wenn man irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, die Flintstones guckt oder so und die haben dann einfach ein scheiß Essen. Man denkt immer, das kann nicht wahr sein. Und die haben auch immer so leckere Bissen. Die beißen auch so eine leckere Art, so dieses in Comics hat Essen immer so eine geile Konsistenz. Aber alles hat die gleiche Konsistenz. Alles hat diese weiche, auch wenn du Brotst, und die essen ja auch ein Stück, ein großes Stück Brot, das ist immer gleich, genau wie Donuts. Es gab bei Asterix mal einen Switch, das in den ersten Filmen gab's, war so und dann irgendwann hat er noch so und dann hat er noch so gezogen und irgendwann hat er so reingebissen in den Oberlix und dann hat er noch so ein bisschen das Fleisch weggezogen und erst noch ein bisschen Widerstand ist abgerissen. Das ist für mich der grosse Switch in der Asterix-Animationskunst. Da gab es einen Punkt, ab dem haben die gesagt, nee, ab jetzt hat Fleisch einen Widerstand. Ich verstehe, dass du enttäuscht bist. Das ist schon auch enttäuschend, wenn man dann irgendwie diese Donuts sieht mit der Himbeerfüllung und dann geht man in den Laden und denkt dann, bitte was ist hier los? Ich muss mich entscheiden. Ja, wobei man denkt, ich kann jetzt auch den Donutkoch mir vorstellen, der sagt, ja, klar, natürlich, in der Fantasie ist es total toll, aber es ist halt unpraktisch, da in so einen Schmalzkringel die Füllung reinzupressen und du kriegst ja auch mehr Füllung rein, wenn du dann so ein Vanillepudding hast. Stopp, Leute. Ihr macht nichts anderes als Füllung in Teig zu drücken. Dann bitte geht euch mal Mühe. Leute, das ist doch nicht euer Ernst. Man kriegt mittlerweile in den Smartphone scheiß 4K-Kameras, kriegt Füllung in den Kreis Donut.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, ich meine, was heißt es ein Donut füllen?
Ist jetzt natürlich eine metaphysische Frage.
Heißt den Donut füllen das Loch füllen?
Einerseits nicht, weil dann löst sich der Donut auf.
Es gibt Donut Holes.
Ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
Ja, gibt so ein tolles Jerry Seinfeld, bitte. M, müsste ich mal reinziehen, Donut Holes bei YouTube eingeben, wo man auch nicht genau weiß, ich weiß, wie die nicht, was es ist. Ich finde, das ist sehr lustig, obwohl ich nicht verstanden habe, genau, worum es geht. Aber es sind doch so kleine Donut Snacks, glaube ich, so wie man kennt von Laugen Konfitüre. Laugen ist aber sehr deutsches, glaube ich. Naja. Naja, das stimmt gar nicht. Jetzt muss ein Argument. Naja, na gut, okay, mein Argument ist, du stehst auf dem Times Square und willst dir einen Snack holen und gehst zu einer Bude und da kannst du kaufen Hotdog, Pretzel. Ja. Also ist Pretzel da so verankert, dass es direkt nach Hotdog dem Uramerikanischen... Pretzel kommt ja aus dem deutschen Brezel. Ja, aber alles, was in Amerika ist, kommt von anderen Kulturen. So kannst du jetzt nicht gegen amerikanische Kultur. Ja, ich sage ja, es ist was Urdeutsches. Wer teilt, weil die keine Originale haben. Ja, okay, Mister, es ist was Uramerikanisches, das was dein Argument hat. Aber welche Sprache haben Indianer gesprochen? Deutsch, die haben wirklich reines, komplett, man fragt ja warum. Hessisch, hessisch, hatten so einen leichten hessischen Akzent, aber schon genailtes Deutsch. Also wirklich auch teilweise ganz, ganz gleich. Was ich besonders nicht verstehe, es stimmt, dass, das frage ich bestimmt, jede Folge kann sein, aber dass die Nordfriesen genau wie die Süd-, ganz, ganz Südengländer, dass die fliessend sprechen können miteinander, obwohl die einen Englisch sprechen mit einem starken Akzent und die einen platt sprechen. Ich glaube, es gab in Amerika ein Dorf, in dem ganz krass gestochenes Britisch gesprochen wird. Also das ist das Klischee Britisch. Da gibt es ein Dorf in Amerika, wo das noch überlebt hat. Aber das mit den Nordfriesen, das weiß ich nicht. Doch, das habe ich mal gehört, dass die, weil Deutsch und Englisch ist ja nicht so weit auseinander. Also was Satzstrukturen angeht und so und viele Wörter Haus, Maus, ihr kennt sie, dass die halt genauso sprechen, wenn es um Mäusenhäusern geht, dann verstehen die sich ganz gut. Ich habe dein Skript gelesen, Maus im Haus. Maus im Haus muss raus. Stell dir mal vor, es würden Aliens landen und die würden einfach fliessend Marokkanisch sprechen. Und man denkt sich so, Marokko, hallo, was ist da passiert? Und die Marokkaner so, oh scheiße, scheiße, jetzt kommt's raus. Oder deren, also, weil unsere Raumfähren sind bemalt. So, These, auch wenn Aliens kommen, kommen die nicht einfach in reinem Metallraumschiffen, sondern auch die haben Logos drauf. Was, wenn die einfach einzeln das Google-Logo haben? Oder wenn die Höhlenmalerei. Und man denkt sich, okay, wir hätten sie wissen können, die waren auch immer so doof. Oder halt so als Logo so ein Bild von Lenny Kravitz. Und alle so Willkommen auf der Erde Hi! Hi! Und dann begrüsst das Volk mit uns mit Say you, say me. Oder die Aliens sehen selbst alle aus wie Lenny Kravitz. Und Lenny Kravitz wollte uns die ganze Zeit sagen. Und die gesamte Erde schaut gleichzeitig auf Lenny Kravitz. Der sagt, hey, ich bin tot. 2016 gestorben. Wirklich? Weiß ich nicht. Ist er wirklich gestorben? Ich dachte heute Morgen, dass Josef Ratzinger getot wäre. Nein, Ratz, sie lebt. Ich weiß schon, dass er lebt. Aber man kennt sich ja, man erwischt sich manchmal mit so Gedanken, so hat er nicht, ist er nicht? Ich kann dir schwören, der ist 2017 gestorben. Kann der eigentlich nicht, also kann der, wenn jetzt irgendwie der aktuelle Papst stirbt, kann Razzis nochmal machen? Razzi macht's nochmal? Das ist die Bildschleifteile. Wir sind wieder Papst. Wir sind schon wieder Papst. Wir sind schon wieder der gleiche Papst. Dass er einfach sagt, ach Leute, komm, fuck it, ich mach's nochmal. Ich spring nochmal rein. Ich weiß es nicht. Schon eine krasse Sache. Es ist für mich so der eine Mensch, dem ich unterstellen würde, ich meine, also jemand, der so viel Macht abgibt, dem würde ich schon unterstellen, dass er der Vertreter Gottes auf Erden ist. Der erste oder der zweite? Nee, Joseph. Ja? Ja, ich meine, wer so viel Macht abgibt und damit ja auch so viel Geld, die ganzen Relikte, dieses eine Zepter, die Krone, die ganzen Sachen.
Der weisse Rauch, den er aus den Augen schiessen kann. Wer so viel Macht abgibt und damit ja auch so viel Geld, die ganzen Relikte, dieses eine Zepter, die Krone, die ganzen Sachen.
Der weiße Rauch, den er aus den Augen schießen kann.
Alles, was er bekommt. Einfach abgegeben und gesagt, nee, ich bin zu alt für diesen Bums.
Ich mache jetzt wieder mein altes Leben, ich gehe jetzt wieder zurück zum Mönch sein.
Was machen die eigentlich die ganzen Sachen?
Spielt der Bingo?
Guckt der Fernsehen? Guckt der Young Pope? Guckt der, wer wird Millionär? Also ist das dann wirklich? Millionario. Cuadres doni di millionario. Die gucken ja auf Italienisch. Ja. Dann bei Bingo so, wenn der Bingo nicht gewinnt, auch so. Komm schon, go on. Ich stehe schlecht auch jetzt. Das ist so peinlich, wenn ich jede Woche vorliege. Und er macht ja sowas genau nicht, weil er Angst hat, dass er sich selber beweist, dass er nichts Besonderes ist. Macht er sowas nicht. Weil du willst dir ja selber nicht beweisen, dass du es nicht bist. Also ich würde kein Glücksspiel mehr spielen, ich würde es nicht mehr drauf ankommen lassen. Das wäre mein, als Papst. Das ist so auch der Name seiner Autobiografie. Ich habe es nicht mehr drauf ankommen lassen. Als Papst. Das ist auch der Name seiner Autobiografie. Ich habe es nicht mehr drauf ankommen lassen. Ich bin angekommen. Wenn du angekommen bist, musst du es nicht mehr drauf ankommen lassen. Du musst es nicht mehr drauf ankommen lassen, weil du es schon bist. Ja. Naja. Übrigens, die Börse schwankt. Jesus. Fucking Christ. Es tut mir so leid. Ich wurde hochgepriesen, als Stefan Gordon Gekko teete. Ich hab's gelesen, ich hab's gelesen. Und dann ist leider der Wunderjunge wurde es. So, und jetzt, der Wunderjunge versteht aber nicht, was los ist. Weil der Wunderjunge hat ja angelegt den Time Warner. Ja. Und man kann sagen ... Wegen Harry Potter, ne, wegen der App. Wegen der App. Die jetzt aber ein Flop war. Die ist noch gar nicht rausgekommen. Doch, die haben wir aber schon gesehen. Ich meine aber eine andere App, die Pokémon-Go-artige App, die noch rauskommt. Ich habe, kann man sagen, 1000 Euro auf Time Warner gesetzt. So, jetzt wurde die übernommen von AT&T, das amerikanische Telekom. Oh ja, die hassen alle. Und jetzt muss man mal sagen, ich dachte immer, dass die übernommenen Firmen, und so ist es ja auch, die machen einen Kursgewinn. Ich habe mich, Stefan Gordon Gekko hat sich also schon in seinem Marmorbüro mit meinem Maragoni-Schreibtisch gefreut, dass ich jetzt gewonnen habe. Jetzt habe ich aber nur noch 500 Euro. Ich habe 500 Euro verloren. Wow, das ist ein halbes Boosted Board. Das ist ein Boosted-Board. Habe ich verloren, weil AT&T Time Warner gekauft hat. Und ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, wie die Börse funktioniert. Wenn mich jetzt mein Kind in der U-Bahn fragt, wie funktioniert die Börse, warum habe ich kein Geld für Schuhe, würde ich die U-Bahn angucken und sagen, ich weiß es nicht. Ich wüsste es, aber dann wurde Time Warner von AT&T gekauft. Scheiße. Dann wurde Time Warner von einem Star Wars Vehicle gekauft. AT&T. Ich habe letztens eine junge Frau in der U-Bahn gesehen, die hat so eine Harry Potter App gespielt. Dann dachte ich mir, katsching, für Stefan Tietze. Aber anscheinend war es nicht das Richtige. Die ist auch kostenlos. Leute, wollt ihr kein Geld verdienen? Ich will, dass ihr Geld verdient. Ich schaue gerade wieder die Harry Potter Filme durch. Ich habe ja letztens schon Episode 4 kritisiert, jetzt bin ich bei Episode 6. Episode 5 ist so ein schlechter Film. Also der Film ist nicht schlecht, aber irgendwo hat sich J.K. verfranst. Also nach Episode 4 hat sie sich, glaube ich, komplett verfranst. Weil Episode 5 ergibt auch nicht mehr so viel Sinn. Weil du hast der Höhepunkt von Episode 5, wir erinnern uns, Episode 5 ist ja der mit dieser unerträglichen Direktorin. Der Ordensphönig. Genau, mit der Umbridge, Dolores Umbridge. Von Stephen King gepriesen als der beste Filmbösewicht aller Zeiten. Umbridge? Nee, der beste Fiktionale Bösewicht. Ist nicht wirklich, ist ziemlich viel Klischee. Vor allem, die Figur ist interessant für 60 Prozent des Films, und dann verschwindet die Figur. Die Figur hat keinen Arg. Die Figur wird aufgebaut und übernimmt die Macht, und jetzt hat sie die Macht in Hogwarts, und jetzt ist ihr Terrorregime. Aber sie verschwindet im Wald für den Rest des Films. Die wird verschleppt von den Minotauren. Ja, von von diesem Treu. Und am Ende des Films heißt es... Von den Minotaurern. Genau, aber sie hat auch so eine Begegnung mit diesem Treu, mit dem Bruder von Hagrid. Das ist meine Argumentationssteroge. Ich wiederhole, was ich gesagt habe. Und am Ende des Films taucht sie wieder auf und man denkt sich, ihr habt diese Figur, also da muss doch irgendwas in einem Hauptplot. Das ist ja immer so die Idee, dass es immer diesen neuen Lehrer gibt für den Dark Arts Arts und dieser neue Lehrer greift immer irgendwie den Hauptplot ein. Umbridge nicht, gar nicht. Und stattdessen gibt es den Showdown zwischen Dumbledore und Voldemort. Das ist der große Showdown. Dumbledore und Voldemort kämpfen gegeneinander, wo bis jetzt immer die Argumentation war, Harry ist sicher in Hogwarts, weil Dumbledore so stark ist. Und jetzt aus dem Nichts, auch Dumbledore hat man 90 % des Films nicht gesehen. Erst am Ende kommt er. Und das Problem ist, in Harry Potter 5 stirbt Sirius Black. Warum, und in der Nebenszene, in dem Nebensatz so, oh nein, ich rette dich, und Voldemort so, so Bittatrix, äh, Sub, Avada Kedavra. Warum ist denn nicht der Showdown, Voldemort gegen Sirius Black, eine Figur, die stirbt in dem Film, die du aufbaust mit dem Orden des Phönix, warum hat die denn nicht den Showdown? Die stirbt ja, und dann kann der sich im grossen Showdown und dann opfern, warum stirbt denn eine Figur, jetzt ist die grosse Frage, also das ist so nervig, warum hat der Showdown eine Figur, die nicht aufgetaucht ist im gesamten Film, das ist sogar Plotpunkt, oh Dumbledore hält sich zurück.
Aber jetzt ist die grosse Frage, kannst du in einem, okay, sorry, einfach dramaturgisch dumm. Ja, man kann nur mal bei J.K. sagen, dass das sieben von acht gut sind und fünf halt einfach crap ist. Man muss, also um kurz Just Kidding Rowling in Schutz zu nehmen. Nee, eben nicht Just Kidding. So, man muss mal kurz sagen, jetzt ist die Frage, muss man im fünften Installment eines Films noch darauf achten, was die innerdramaturgische Arc in einem Film ist? Ja, natürlich musst du das. Naja, auf eine andere Art hat das... Immer noch ein Film. Die Filme sind wirklich nicht gut. Also ab muss man, würde ich sagen, hinten raus. David Yale, wo man denkt wirklich, ich finde, also der dritte Film ist überragend und der hat ganz tolle visuelle Ideen, richtig tolle visuelle Ideen, wo man kurz erahnen kann, was hätte noch daraus werden können. Und dann aber, und dann muss man sagen, sind die Filme aber nur noch geguckt worden und werden auch immer noch geguckt, weil die Story insgesamt cool ist, weil die Metastory, weil die funktioniert und cool ist und, die Bücher gelesen haben und die Bücher funktionieren.
Wo ich auch gar nicht weiß, ist es in den Büchern auch so? Ja, das ist ja nicht das Problem der Filme, sondern eher das Problem der Bücher, weil du hast ja das, was Harry Potter cool macht, das Magische verbunden mit dem Ordinären. Kein Kind geht gerne in die Schule, du verbindest das Langweiligste mit dem Aufregendsten. Schule und Magie, geil. Diese tolle Fantheorie, dass er sich das alles ausdenkt
in seinem Kämmerlein, seinem Besenkämmerlein unter der Treppe.
Ja. Was Sinn macht, weil er sich dann in diese Welt flüchtet und diese magische Welt flüchtet, weil er halt alleine damit nicht klarkommt. Was ja jeder irgendwie kennt, weil jeder in der Schule sitzt und sich vorstellt, jetzt der Held zu sein, irgendwie in einer Parallelwelt. Aber du hast diesen Kontrast, langweilige Schule und aufregende Magie, das funktioniert aber nur so lange, wie Harry Potter eine Identifikationsfigur ist, er ist ein normaler Schüler, er muss auch Hausaufgaben machen, klar, er lebt so Abenteuer nebenbei, aber er muss auch Hausaufgaben machen, er muss auch die Lehrer hören, nur in Episode 5 wird er zum der Auserwählte, und ab dann wird's kritisch, weil dann ist alles, was bis jetzt cool war, musst du noch mal eine komplett neue Dramaturgie aufmachen. Warum ist es immer noch cool? Ist immer der Auserwählt. Nee, ist er nicht. Er ist von Anfang an der Auserwählung. Ja, aber es ist der, der entweder zufällig ein Abenteuer stolpert oder ist der, der halt als einziger seine Freunde rettet. Aber er ist nie der, wo man sagt, so jetzt kommt es auf dich an, nur du kannst Voldemort töten. Und ab Episode 5 ist es wirklich so, dass sich alles dreht, weil dann ist er irgendwie, dann wird es so super düster und dann schafft, finde ich, schaffen die Bücher und die Filme es nicht, nochmal eine neue Welt aufzumachen, weil dann musst du komplett neu denken, weil dann hast du eine neue Protagonistenfilme, dann hast du halt Superman, der zwar auch noch Probleme hat, aber der halt schon für was Großes geschaffen ist, weil bis fünf ist die Dramaturgie ja einfacher Schuljunge, mach das Unglaubliche und am Ende sagen alle, wow Harry, wie kon wie konntest du das schaffen? Toll! Aber ab fünf ist die Dramaturgie,
auserwählter Superheld schafft es, sein Schicksal zu erfüllen.
Und das ist eine neue Geschichte.
Der bis dahin, muss man auch sagen, nichts geschissen bekommen hat.
Er kriegt alles immer durch seine Freunde hin.
Er war mutig und so, von Freundschaft, aber es war nie so.
Und das ist das Problem, dass das nicht genau funktioniert.
Das ist genau wie bei Neo, bei Matrix,
ist auch sobald er da super allmächtig und der Auserwählte, dann wird es immer nicht so geil. Ich glaube, es gibt keinen Film, der das richtig gut hinbekommt. Also das ist immer so diese Heldenreise. Du fängst an als Normaler, dann irgendwie Mentor und so und irgendwann bist du krass und tötest den Drachen und dann ist aus. Aber dieses du bist krass und tötest den Drachen muss möglichst schnell gehen, weil wenn dieser Teil zu lange dauert, so du hast das magische Schwert, töt den Drachenfilm aus, aber wenn du das magische Schwert vier Filme lang hast, wird das halt irgendwann saulangweilig, weil du denkst dir, gut, du bist ja Auserwählte, du bist mächtig und dann musst du noch den Horcrux finden. Was ich dann cool finde, dann geht es in Harry Potter ja darum, und das ist ja auch schon Teil vier so, wie er mit dieser Rolle klarkommt. Und das finde ich, da würde ich dir widersprechen, weil ich finde es gerade cool, wenn du dann nämlich halt, das ist dann halt eine sehr spezielle, nicht mehr so relatable natürlich, weil du halt jetzt plötzlich ist eine Identifikationsfigur jemand, der der Auserwählte ist, der, wie du sagst, der Superheld ist, aber trotzdem geht es ja dann um die Arc quasi, wie er damit klarkommt, seinen Platz in dieser Welt zu erfüllen. Absolut, aber den Arc finde ich nicht mehr gut, der ist nicht mehr gut gesetzt. Ja, aber das ist eine geschmächtrische Frage.
Ich finde trotzdem, dass es insgesamt dramaturgischen Sinn ergibt.
Weil Teil vier ist doch der grosse Mobbingfilm, wo er ...
Teil vier ist der Pubertätsfilm.
So mit Ah Tanzen und Ah, erste Mal Liebeleien und so.
Wo er gemobbt wird und so, weil er angeblich den ...
Potter, du hast doch den anderen Zettel bei dir reingeworfen und so.
Also man kennt die Sprüche. Potter, Plotter und so. Niemand glaubt ihm mehr, irgendwann glaubt man ihm. Und er wird gemobbt und nicht gemocht. Und er kommt trotzdem damit klar und lernt dann, sich auf seine Freundin zurück zu besinnen. Ich weiß nicht. Ist auch immer noch cool. Ich gucke mir die Filme immer noch gerne an. Ja, aber wenn man an Harry Potter denkt, denkt man immer an Szenen aus 1 bis 4 und nie aus Szenen 5 bis 8, würde ich sagen, weil man Harry Potter verbindet mit diesen Kinder in der Schule und, oh, der Lehrer ist vielleicht böse, aber wenn es dann heißt, okay, gut, der Lehrer ist definitiv böse, ich bin der Auserwählte, Kämpfen, krass, Schule ist nicht mehr wichtig, ist nicht mehr der gleiche Film, aber gut. Es gibt ein tolles Video-Essay auf YouTube, dass Harry Potter eigentlich verkappt, also nicht nur Coming-of-Age sind und Fantasy sind, sondern verkappte Mystery-Stories sind. Weil du die ganze Zeit, eigentlich jeder Teil wird ein Mystery gelöst. So in Teil 1 ist es, wer ist gerade der Bösewicht? Und du kriegst immer die Hinweise mit an die Hand, wie in der alten Sherlock-Holmes-Mechanik,
wo es Arthur Conan Doyle
immer einem die Hinweise an die Hand gegeben hat
und du das puzzelt schon theoretisch, wenn du nicht
blöd wärst, weil du gleich ein Mensch bist,
der Dinge überliest, der Dinge
nicht richtig sieht, weil die
gerade nicht im Kontext genannt werden, sondern so
verstreut. Aber wenn Sherlock Holmes das Buch lesen würde,
könnte er den Fall lösen. Könnte er den Fall lösen.
Und das macht zum Beispiel die
Sherlock-Holmes-Serie macht das zum Beispiel nicht so.
Ah, Moment, hat sie später nicht mehr gemacht. Hat sie später nicht mehr gemacht. Am Anfang schon. Da wurde Sherlock Holmes schlecht. Nee, aber auch am Anfang bei den Deduktionen, die kannst du nicht. Also wenn du den Typen siehst, dann hast du einfach diese Montagen, diese 1,30-Montagen, oh, du hast gerade einen schlauen Typen. Ja, das stimmt. Du könntest nicht, wenn du in der Totalen diesen Typen siehst, wo er gleich sagt, der betrübt seine Frau, weil er hat Kreideflecken auf seinen Schuhen, weil er die Tafel der Frau abwischt, die ich kenne. Also du kannst es nicht lösen. Aber so den Grundplot kannst du schon. Aber das wurde auch, dass es gegen Ende immer mehr Magie wurde bei Sherlock und am Anfang noch nachvollziehbar. Genau, richtig genau. Und das macht, so läuft Harry Potter ja auch quasi, dass dass so die ganze Zeit kriegst du Hinweise an die Hand. Und tatsächlich hat sie das so geschafft, dass Charaktere immer mit einem Adjektiv oft, also sie wiederholt ganz oft, dass, weiß nicht, Snape rabenschwarze Haare hat zum Beispiel. Und irgendwann benutzt sie rabenschwarz mit etwas, wo du jetzt wissen könntest, okay, das hängt mit Snape zusammen. Ah, okay. Aber sie benutzt, das ist wie quasi, und man merkt, meine Phase hat sich noch nicht beendet, wie bei Wagner als Leitmotiv zum Beispiel, wo du schon in der Musik hörst, was gleich dramaturgisch passiert.
Wenn du das Schwertleitmotiv hörst mit Siegfrieds Musik, weißt du, okay, vielleicht kriegt er gleich das Schwert.
Und dann löst sich schon der Plot quasi, im Kopf hast du den schon, unterbewusst, aber bewusst hast du es noch nicht.
Und dadurch freust du dich umso mehr, wenn dann wirklich dieses rabenschwarze Detail mit Snape zusammenhängt. Das fand ich ganz interessant. Das ist cool. Ja, die ist schon gut. Wir machen mal einen Harry Potter Filmfights und dann müssen wir mal alles, welches der beste Teil, schlechtester Teil, beste Figur. Wir machen vor allem Antenna Askar war Teil zwei, auf jeden Fall. Noch vor Antenna Online? Ja, vielleicht vor Antenna Online. Antenna Alabass, ja? Ja. Ich muss kurz Werbung machen, weil du am Freitag bei Rocket Beans ein ganz tolles neues Format machst, ein cooles Pen & Paper, neuer Art. Ich würde es nicht Pen & Paper nennen, da haben wir schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht. Wir nennen es nicht Pen & Paper, wir nennen es eine coole Show, die ich sehr fasziniert. Hastasziniert habe. Hast du auch eine kleine Rolle? Freut euch drauf. Es geht grob, weil ich bin ja ein riesiger True-Crime-Documentary-Fan. Es geht um Crime, es geht darum, wer hat es getan, es geht darum, genau, es geht darum, Fall zu lösen. Und ganz zu empfehlen, auf Netflix, schaut euch unbedingt an The Staircase. Ja genau, das hat mir schon mehrere empfohlen. The jetzt, haben wir schon mehrere empfohlen. The Staircase geht um, das hat bei mir schon langsam in den Stand, ich muss es mir angucken, geht um einen Fiction-Writer, der angeblich seine Frau umgebracht hat, weil die wurde am Ende einer Treppe gefunden und überall war Blut. Und das ist auch am Ende quasi, warum er, warum alle ihn für schuldig halten, weil da überall Blut ist und wenn man von der Treppe fällt, normalerweise nicht so viel Blut ist. Und es ist total interessant, weil es geht die ganze Zeit hin und her und du guckst halt den ganzen Anwälten bei der Arbeit zu. Und jetzt ist bei YouTube eine Follow-up-Dokumentation aufgetaucht, die eine alternative Theorie verfolgt. Weil bis zum Ende ist nicht klar, also man hat schon eine Meinung als Zuschauer, aber bis zum Ende ist nicht genau klar, wer das getan hat und ob er es wirklich getan hat.
Und dann gibt es diese Theorie. Du musst dir vorstellen, dass du zehn Stunden lang guckst diesen Fall an und beide Anwaltsteams, die gegeneinander argumentieren. Ganz am Ende guckst du dann diese Dokumentation auf YouTube, wo beschuldigt wird, dass es den Mord begangen hat, eine Eule. Weil diese Eulen sehr häufig in der Gegend vorkommen, Federn gefunden wurden auf der Treppe und quasi die Risse im Schädel dem von Eulenkrallen nahekommen. Und das würde so die Federn erklären, die fucking Federn, die ganzen Wunden, alle Fragezeichen werden gelöst und der Täter ist weg, aus dem Nichts. Also die Eule ist, und das ist sehr wahrscheinlich, viele Forensiker sagen, es kann durchaus diese Eule sein. Und diese Dokumentation verliert kein Wort darüber. Also ist meine Theorie, dass dieses Dokumentarteam jahrelang diesen, und das ist wirklich 20 Jahre Jahre lang diesen Fall begleitet und irgendwann herausfindet,
okay, es war wahrscheinlich eine Eule und sagt, fuck it, das ist mir zuwährendenehm,
das lassen wir, das kommt nicht in die Dokumentation,
es war wahrscheinlich eine Eule.
Entweder das oder die Dokumentation wurde
von Eulen gedreht. Ja, oder von Eulen.
Einfach um den Verdacht wegzuschieben.
Nee, es war doch ein Mensch. Die Frage ist, wo ist diese
Eule jetzt halt? Holy shit.
Und ich glaube, ich bin der festen Überzeugung,
widersprecht mir, guckt euch
den Staircase an, dann
Vielen Dank. Die Frage ist, wo ist diese Eule jetzt halt? Holy shit! Und ich glaube, ich bin der festen Überzeugung, widersprecht mir, guckt euch den Staircase an, dann die Owl Theory und dann sagt mir bitte, das war keine Eule. Also, ich kann mir keinen anderen Grund vorstellen. Übrigens geil, dass es im Englischen ein Wort gibt für das Geräusch, was wir machen. Hooting. Hooting. Hoot, hoot. Hoot! Ich weiß nicht, irgendein Setup-Comedian, Brian irgendwas, hat auch ein langes Bild über, warum es Hoot, hoot, hoot. Hoot, hoot. Genau. Ich weiß nicht, irgendein Zell-Comedian, Brian Irgendwas, hat auch ein langes Bild über, warum es Hoot heißt und nicht einfach Hu, weil keine Eule macht, Hoot. Wie Hooters gibt es ja in Hamburg. So, das war das Podcast-Ufo, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, haut rein. Ganz kurz, wie sieht es aus mit der WC-Ente? Keine News über die WC-Ente. Keine News von der WC-Ente, falls die Leute jetzt wirklich Fingernägel kauen. Wir machen nächste Woche weiter, weil von euch haben manche Initiative ergriffen und Dinge geschrieben. Da können wir auf eine Antwort uns freuen. Keine Angst, die WC-Ente. Von uns gibt es keine Antwort mehr, weil Johnson & Son uns leider nicht mehr zurückschreibt. Okay, aber die WC-Ente-Story geht auf jeden Fall weiter. Wir halten euch auf dem Laufenden in der nächsten Folge das Podcast-Ufo, wenn wir wieder landen. Bevor wir gleich landen, noch eine grosse, grosse Ankündigung. Denn wir lassen uns nicht lumpen. Die Podcast-Ufo-Tour geht in die zweite Runde. Nach der grossen Erstmonokal- und Berlin-Tour 2018 folgt die, gibt es später noch umsonst als Podcast-Tour 2018, 2019. Wow, wann geht's los? Es geht, ich habe keine Ahnung, wann es losgeht, im Oktober, glaube ich. Irgendwann im Oktober, Ende des Jahres geht es los. Wir machen Ende des Jahres, ab Oktober, jeden Monat an einem Ort eine Tour. Und jetzt müsst ihr gut aufpassen. Ich weiß, wir sind ein Nebenbeimedium. Ihr müsst aufpassen, jetzt kurz mal einmal, holt euch einen Stift vielleicht und schreibt das kurz mal mit, weil es ist wichtig. Wir sagen euch dann Bescheid, ob wir schon alle Termine bekannt geben. Es kann aber sein, dass wir
erst die ersten vier Termine bekannt geben müssen
und dann folgen noch drei oder sowas.
Und da kann ja eure Stadt
dabei sein, die bei euch ist. Wir wollen
nämlich nicht, dass ihr von München nach Berlin
fahren müsst, das müsst ihr nicht tun,
weil wir vielleicht noch in München spielen
dann danach. Das heißt,
wir spielen auf jeden Fall, die Venues sind diesmal größer, es sind mehr Termine, ihr bekommt alle Tickets. Dafür lege ich meine Hand ins Feuer. So sehr, wie dass man Enten Gummibärchen geben kann. Da sind wir uns mittlerweile sicher. Auf jeden Fall erwartet vielleicht nochmal dann, wir werden aber Bescheid sagen und kommunizieren, ob das jetzt alle Termine sind oder nicht. Auf jeden Fall sind es glaube ich so um die sechs, sieben, acht Termine und da ist eure Stadtminsicherheit dabei. Aber es gibt jetzt noch keine Tickets zum Kauf. Da bin ich mir nicht sicher. Ich weiß nicht genau, wann wir diese Folge hochladen werden, ich weiß nicht genau, wann wir die Termine bekannt geben werden. Wo kann man denn hundertprozentig sicher erfahren, ob Tickets schon zum Verkauf stehen oder nicht? Folgt uns auf twitter.com slash das Podcast Ufo. Auf facebook.com slash das Podcast Ufo 23. Und solange da nichts gepostet ist, und solange da nichts gepostet ist, gibt es auch keine Tickets. Also ihr müsst uns nicht schreiben, ihr müsst uns keine Mails schreiben, sondern folgt uns einfach, haltet die Augen offen und sobald da was steht, gibt es die, davor nicht. Wir werden auch vielleicht auf allen diesen Plattformen bekannt geben, wann der Vorverkauf startet. Ich glaube, ihr kriegt alle Tickets, wenn ihr wollt. Die Venues sind lächerlich groß. Ich sag nur Olympiastadion. Ernsthaft? Ja. Das ganze Olympiastadion. Okay. Das sind nur 60.000. Gut, dann wünschen wir euch eine schöne Woche und haut rein.
Haut rein, wir heben ab.
Wir machen nächste Woche die letzte Folge vor der Sommerpause.
Wir sind schon abgehoben.
Dann bin ich kurz im Urlaub.
Ja, aber dann bist du zwei Wochen im Urlaub.
Ich bin nicht lange im Urlaub, aber bis dahin freut euch auf jeden Fall.
Macht's gut, wir heben ab, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao, ciao.